9470 lead for denver do if you get to
the rim I didn't know he could get to
the rim and up like that to the first
quarter half side buckets up by 15
[Applause]
[Music]
swingin Harris Jeffries got
[Applause]
three-sixty rehearse I think he goes up
thinks he's gonna get some fresh or 360s
with Harry Harris Harris on the loose it
in there my rattle just never saw the
ball he was the big that was bad versus
on tegus got a six and a stone Harris
can't erase it
[Applause]
see hint and see how low it is yeah like
he understands where the balls going to
be and then those the big finish putting
kyle korver in a poster you click this
and right here Pam Goodrich is Yuri West
yo kids back
the poster it's the past another assist
by yogic smurfing facts there's the foul
by Scola once it's passed not sure about
the past to limp but fake high go low
[Applause]
simmer put it on spin nice kick to
Harris and Harris Thomas trap and Dirk
attends the steal and carry Harris what
a nice outlet by the Bosnian beasts
gallon arc made two of three
three-pointers in the first half he now
has 449 his career as Gary Harris gets
the lobby moves it up but watch it's a
back screen just wraps read and McCoy
seemed just running into Gary nice to
have that play back on yeah Nikola it is
trailing Gary around these screens not
Gomez he got a box him out of there
big hair not Gomez now the Nuggets habit
Gary Harris right
[Applause]
watch it gets it to the right whoa
just keeps it there big hands it all the
way in will you say that ball is slick
that ball went slippery right there to
see ball man all the time
doctor 9.6 rebounds oh yes give me a
late candidate new Beasley said I told
you my ankle felt better tell you what
these guys are energized they're playing
with an edge well they're being
aggressive and you know what probably
got fouled - he got hit in the hip
control he's looking left bass sit under
the bass i right then who's that cutter
again very hard physically boys right
there now tie is Joe still
eres with the steel rod it in gear back
don't you drive it again why employers
only trying to set the screen Gary
Harris to the drive slow it up
he's got go back boys get that over play
pretty good pass-down Harris on the
rocks at sectional whoa Gary Harris and
going early
[Music]
it's a ten-nothing run for the Nuggets
who lead by five tips back for the three
listed he made it a nice shot the one
more pass
she had somebody wired up with Gary
Harris down there's Gary he's just big
hands at happy hair since that one steps
outside waiting for Randolph to jump
he's a man I'm too old to jump sit into
Harris look at mesa plumbing mesa
plumbing is putting his hands over his
head oh my this is impressive Scotty see
y'all over here is it move how about the
two masses dunks maybe of the year both
in this game nice play by Plumlee era
slows it down need more of that 206 to
go third quarter Hornets by 23
[Music]
18 on the shot clock plenty of time
[Applause]
talked into the fish love this it goes
by levert squeeze Mike Carroll who I
think he may have just taken Millsap
crown right here now this is outstanding
work
well that's unbelievable hang time
Joseph did an excellent job
he definitely disrupted that release
Chandler finds the open man it's me
[Applause]
or out keep its would you allow the
deepest
[Applause]
maybe one of the greatest lamps I have
ever seen who I don't think it gets out
of the right hand stays in the right
moves in the right and a little George
[Music]
good Gary Harris knife again and he
throws it down throwing it down in
Beantown in the basket Wilt Chamberlain
used to do it all the time Wow
Gary Harris jump off 17 never breaks it
down this goes straight back up when he
goes in he's got four points
mao-chan defense I told you the word is
the number one team in the league in
defensive rating Harrison the lane by
Gary Harris he's knocked flat he'll head
to the line
switched hands whoop two games are oh he
just went up showed up with the big hand
right went to the left watch this let me
show it to you and then you hear it
whoop back to the left hand and a hand
one opportunity
a good defense there Royce ordeal has
come on Gary Harris God s love these
underneath the basket you don't cover up
you don't stop him and watch how the
[ __ ] think they liked it at all nines
only two of threes he struggled here in
the second half just two three go Gary
Harris that's good
Yogesh thought about the three no he's
gonna back it out great gets it down
with the left hand thread the deal
passed there good do it it's back in use
this back in one point for regulation yo
kitch
there is gonna be games
[Applause]
joke it yolk is running out of time here
finds Gary Harris cash money leaves and
as finishes the 25 the three the finish
they review all these shots of course he
got it off as you can see
[Applause]
precarious at the bar
see all those curls the veins have
stopped that's a key success
beautiful Paris manipulates it puts it
in going to be Glade bow with your
office on Friday stolen lonely pass
Harris any chance it
definitely look awkward it's almost like
Gary's leg hits Johnson present his
defense is pesky tonight so far and the
shot is blocked very here Harris Rams it
through six for jumping jack yep
[Music]
eight to shoot gotta look into change to
get that ball inside the milsat derriere
is long ginny knocks it in
Carrie knocks at depth oh here we go
against 4640 Calliope Eris
[Applause]
[Music]
let's say get the Knicks Gary Harris
poster series Julius Randle is going to
be in that one right there he just went
over the top of random 1.9 here Gary
Harris here the bags look like maybe the
right toe just cruises the line a little
bit
you twine warbirds anytime that are
dismissively
yeah kind of pumps up the crowd a little
bit Gary's got a layout he throws it
right in cristianos face his little
talking trash y'all he was doing it
we're already trying to slip jetty
Osmond Gary Harris got a look he's got
that look
well they say Kyrie is the best vault
never on the league with apologies to
Stefan
[Music]
his strenghtens look he just goes right
by Hayward right there he's already beat
I think Denver could have more finishes
like that
now Gary heiress comes five straight
years and they feel up to series wins
but obviously last year is disappointing
us McCallum Wow Harris able to hang
finish through contact for three-point
opportunity he flicked it back Harris
has it he'll race a depose it down hose
that not an Atwood Gary Harris Harris is
ahead he's got it he shouldn't
and I don't think he did not purchase
[Applause]
smile she bridges smiles in the endemic
xenos awful to hear about this summer
yep sings oh gosh Gary's got me for the
summer Gary Harris for three gets it
back
first three made in this corner for
Denver here here watch the screen yo
couch is gone out darienne's Lane attack
yes he just he just got the defender on
his back
Nuggets 103 we just saw that there spend
a lot of time there having a
conversation with Jason Phillips Parris
Wow hammer sit down
[Applause]
[Music]
watch sheet Crowder get out of the way
tube says I do not want to be on a Gary
Harrah's poster made a business decision
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
g-gary the street that just ran right
through the outside and behind the back
Chabot didn't know what to do when he
went behind them back Sam and lucky
didn't fall down good side bad side as
we say in volleyball coverage on the
beach
Gary Harris oh you've seen one of the
year got him up spin to backwards
oh my goodness you said a while ago
trying to get a Spartan maybe this could
be one from Gary Harris move to athletic
for those guys out there
Jamal Murray finds yogurts look at this
pass Harris goes to first
[Applause]
eight Finnish but I mean you'll get
season coming and look at this oh look
at the spinny ass put on that ball great
finished by Harris by the pass - great
job Collins comes over to contest and
then you can do yoke it's Lillard is up
on him yoke it's with one on the shot
clock dumps it off and Harris scores as
a whistle
and Celt a basket by yogic he gives a
little fake and he dropped it down and
there are literally no time left on the
clock
he's slow to get up still down the other
end
Harris spins shot is good brings on the
ground so you're playing four on five
but Harris takes it at Leonard legs get
tangled up he flips it up with its left
hand what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content